the second
topic i want to discuss is i want to
talk about
robustness of graph neural networks so
that's the question is how robust
are these models against let's say
adversarial
or any other type of attack so uh
this is motivated by kind of more
broader field of deep learning where in
recent years
we have we have seen impressive
performance of deep learning models
in a variety of applications especially
let's say in computer vision natural
language and so on
but what has been shown is that
if these models are applied to the to
the real world
and we have different types of actors in
then the question becomes how robust are
these models
to um to various kinds of attacks
and one example is a notion of an
adversarial attack
where for example you can take the
original input image and ask the neural
network what do you think this is and
the neural network is going to say
oh it's a it's a it's a panda
but what you can do then is very
slightly perturb
values of the pixels um you know just
you you adds a bit of noise and now the
neural network will get
totally confused and it will say oh it's
a it's
it's a gibbon right it's a monkey so the
point being
is that to a human when we look at this
they both look like
images of a panda to us but by being
very careful
and systematic very adversarial you can
change the prediction of the neural
network
and these types of adversarial examples
are also reported for
natural language processing model audio
processing
and and the point is that the adversary
can very quickly
um change the prediction of our model by
only slightly
manipulating the input so
the existence of the of adversarial
examples prevents
reliable deployment of deep learning
models in the real world
because adversaries may try to actively
hack the
lead deep learning model and kind of
sidestep it
and the model performance this way may
be much much worse than what we'd expect
right and what has been found is the
deep learning models are often not
robust
and this is a very active area of
research to maze to make
these models robust against adversarial
attacks or adversarial
examples so let's look
in this part of the lecture about how
would you formalize the notion of
adversarial example
to graph neural networks and r graph
neural networks
robust to adversarial examples um and
the premise is that
if common applications of graph neural
networks
you know involve let's say platforms
that are accessible to the public or
that there is some financial monetary
interest behind them
then these types of attacks may happen
so for example
in recommender systems social networks
and social
and search engines there's always some
types of actors attackers
who may want to manipulate the system so
the adversaries have incentive to
manipulate the
input graphs and basically try to change
or flip or hack
the predictions of the graph neural
network
so how are we going to study to set up
the framework to study robustness of
graph neural networks
to study robustness of graph neural
networks we are going to
specifically consider the following
setting we are going to look at
semi-supervised node classification and
we are going to use the
graph convolutional neural network model
just as an example
and the idea is right we have a
partially labeled graph
so here's the example we have a graph
and we are thinking about node
classification
nodes have features some nodes already
have
labels and we would like to predict uh
labels uh for the other nodes as i
uh as i show uh here
so then the question is the following
right what we are going to do is we are
going to first describe
several um types of attacks that the
adversary may do
then we are going to talk about uh you
know how a graph neural network
uh or a gcn how how would
how would that how we could try to hack
it
um and this means that um adversary
adversary needs to know what underlying
model we are using
and then we are going to mathematically
formalize the attack problem
as an optimization problem and then i'll
show some empirical results
to show how vulnerable gcns are to
adversarial attacks so
let's first talk about what would a an
attack
to a graph uh look like uh and we are
going to talk about
direct in and indirect attacks
uh and in particular the way we are
going to think about this is the
following
let's say there is a target note t whose
label
prediction we want to change and let's
say that there are some other nodes in
the network
um let's call them s that the attacker
can modify so these are the nodes
that the attacker controls and now what
can the
you know what can the attacker what can
the attacker do
so let's say that there is a direct
attack
and a direct attack means that the
attacker
is the target node right so the attacker
owns the target node
so what the attacker can then do the
attacker can modify the target node
features
for example they can change change their
social network profile
they can change the website content uh
they can also add connections
um from the target to other nodes in the
network like you know they can buy
likes they can buy followers they can
make friendships uh things like that
um and they can also of course decide to
remove some connections
you know they can unfollow users they
can drop friendships if that would allow
them to
flip the classification label for that
target node
that they own so this is what we call a
direct attack
because the attacker owns the node the
the node that the attacker wants to flip
is is is the attacker so for example if
you think about some kind of
spam detection the attacker may want to
say huh
you know the social network is
classifying me as a spammer
what do i need to change so that the
social network won't classify me as a
spammer anymore
and they may change their attributes
they may change who they follow
or they may they may drop some of the
links in the network
there is also a second type of attack
which we call an
indirect attack and in an indirect
attack a target node is not
the attacker node so it means that the
attacker does not
account does not control the target but
the attacker
can control some other nodes in the
network
and the attacker can change let's say
the features of those nodes
so the attacker can change the
connections of those nodes
and attacker can also basically can add
them or they can
remove those connections and you know
what is a realistic example for this
case
it is that for example the attacker
wants to
harm some other let's say innocent node
in the network
so the attacker is going to to change um
the the properties of the nodes it
controls to perhaps
change the label of the target node they
don't control so perhaps the target node
is not a spammer
but the attacker wants somebody to be
excluded from the network so they want
them
to be labeled as a spammer so they are
going to now
change uh the network structure the
connections to the target node
so that the neural network is going to
classify the target node differently
even though the target node
has no clue that uh they are being
under attack so how are we formalizing
the
adversarial attack the goal is that we
wanna
maximize something subject to some
constraints and the
idea will be that we want to maximize
the change of the target node
label so we want to change the target
node label subject to
very small uh graph manipulation right
we want to manipulate the underlying
graph as little as possible such that
the class probabilities of the target
node are going to change
right basically the idea is that if the
graph manipulation is too large
it will be easily detected um by the
uh by the by this agent by the social
network and it will say hey there is an
attack going on
but if a successful if an attack is
successful
then we should be able to change just a
small number of edges
maybe a few features here and there and
this will be kind of unnoticeably small
manipulation
that is going to flip uh the prediction
the let's say the class
label for the target node uh
significantly
so the way what the way we want to think
of this is we'll say perhaps
there is a class or a label to which the
target node gets
uh classified right now so what we want
to do is we want to
decrease the probability of the correct
class and we want to want to increase
the probability of some
other chosen class let's say class 3 in
our case
so how are we going to formalize this
mathematically
we are going to say that we have the
adjacency matrix of the original graph
and we have the feature information of
nodes of the original graph
and then we'll also have a prime and x
prime
to be manipulated graphs so these are
the graphs after
the attack after we have manipulated
them and we'll have the adjacency matrix
and we'll have the feature matrix
and our goal or assumption is that the
two
that the manipulation is small right our
goal is that is
manipulation the changing the adjacency
matrix the change in the node features
is um unnoticeably small so basically we
want to preserve
basic graph statistics like degree
distribution uh note feature statistics
and so on
and as i mentioned the graph
manipulation can either be direct
changing the node and feature and the
features and connections of the target
node
or it can be indirect which means we are
we may want to change
um the connections and features of some
other nodes in the network
with the hope to change the uh label of
the target node
so um now that we said what what we want
to do let's formalize it so we will be
given a target node v
and let us what the
what the the system is going to do
uh you know let's say the social network
is going to learn
the original um the classifier over
the original graph right so it's going
to say oh let's you know define this
likelihood over the training data
and let's optimize our neural network
model parameters
over the training data and then um you
know the now that the model has been
trained
how is the prediction going to look like
we'll say ah for this target node of
interest v
uh let's classify it in into the class
that our predictor f
our neural network with parameters theta
star that we have trained
uh applied to this graph um this is our
prediction right we are going to predict
the class
of for this node v that has the highest
uh predicted
uh probability just kind of standard
stuff
now uh the attacker comes into play so
what the attacker is going to do
the attacker um can uh what they can do
is
they cannot change the parameters of the
model right the
the model parameters cannot be changed
because
you know the social network whoever the
operator has already trained the model
and has deployed it
so the model parameters um won't
necessarily uh
be able to be to be changed so um
what we can what we can do in this case
is that the gcn
um we can like the way we will think
about it
is that we are going to think about it
that the gcn will now be learned
over the manipulated graph right so
basically we are going to change
a to b a prime and we are going to
change x to be x
prime um and now the the
we are going to train over this
manipulated graph and we are going to
get
a different set of parameters and then
the gcn's prediction of the target grow
node may change both because the input
is different
as well as because the parameters we
learned will be different because we
learned them on a different graph and
with different node features
and we want the prediction to change
after the graph is manipulated right so
we want the
class for node v after manipulation to
be different
than what the class was before the
manipulation so
we want to flip the uh
the the class so the way we are going
uh to do this is the following right the
way we are going to do this
is to say we want to change the
predicted probability for a
of a of a class of a given node um
between the true class and the
manipulated class
right so uh here i'm saying f is
outputting the probability
um for a given node to be of a given
class
so here i want the predicted log
probability of a newly predicted class
c star prime to be to increase
while i want to decrease
the predicted log probability of the
originally predicted class we want this
term to decrease and we want that term
to
to increase so we are going to formulate
this into this delta
function delta that is basically
changing the prediction
on the target node v it is a change
uh in like in in likelihood of the
correct class versus likelihood of the
manipulated class and the way
we make this term this delta high is to
make
this probability here as small as
possible
and we make this probability here as
large
as possible right we want this to be
close to zero and we want this
to be close to one so we want to
increase
the first term the left term and we want
to decrease
the second term so
the way we can write this out as an
optimization problem
we want to say we want to do the arg max
over
the underlying graph structure and the
feature vector
where we want to maximize this delta
right this delta function of the
change in the prediction on the target
subject
to the constraint that the manipulation
of the graph structure and the feature
vector is as small as possible
um and ideally what we'd like to do is
solve this optimization problem uh the
challenge
in optimization in optimizing this
objective if we are on
adversary is that the um adjacency
matrix a
is a discrete object so you cannot take
gradients
against a to decide what edges to
manipulate um
and that's the first challenge and then
the second challenge is that for every
modification to
um to the adjacency matrix and the
feature vector we need to retrain
the underlying graph neural network to
see whether the
prediction uh is uh will flip uh or not
and i won't go into more details here
and you know here's a paper
you can read to learn uh more about this
but essentially the idea the idea here
is
that we want to manipulate the graph
structure and the feature vector as
little as possible
so that the so that the predicted label
of
target node v is going to change um as
much
as possible so
imagine we are now able to solve this
optimization problem
and we can ask ourselves how easy it is
to find these
strategically placed edges and changes
in the feature vector
that lead that would uh let the model to
completely wrongly make predictions on a
given node
so here we are working on a
semi-supervised node classification task
with
graph convolutional neural network model
on a paper citation network with
2 800 nodes and about 8 000 edges
and you know this is a six-way
classification task
and what we are doing here is we are
looking at a set of nodes
that belongs to the class six and we
ran the graph neural network we trained
it five times
from random starting points and here we
are saying you know what is the
predicted probability of these nodes
that belong to class six and you can see
that
they have high probabilities so so our
graph neural network is learning well
now imagine we are an attacker and we
say
we want this um class
six so basically research papers that
belong to topic six
we wanna manipulate the underlying graph
structure
to make them belong to class uh seven
all right so this means we are going to
change the adjacency matrix
um and the um see if we can flip
uh their labels um and what is
interesting is if we use this framework
and ask
how many edges do we need to manipulate
in a
direct adversarial attack it turns out
that gcn's prediction
will flip um aft only after modifying
just
five edges at a attached to the target
node
so here i show you for a given target
node in you know five different
uh retrainings just kind of five
different instances
we see that every single time we were
able to flip
the label of this target node who was of
class six to be now of class 7
and the model is super confident that
this node belongs to class 7
even in reality it is in class
6. and to summarize
uh this uh robustness of graph neural
networks against attacks
uh this is summarized here where um
zero would mean is classification margin
intuitively
you can you can think a bit about how
confident um
is the is the or how correct
is is the um is the classification so
if it's positive it means the the the
classification is correct
with a big with a big gap so we are very
confident in correct classifications
and if the classification margin is
negative it would mean
we are wrong and we are and we are wrong
by a lot right we assign
uh high confidence to the wrong
prediction
and we see that you know um with no
attacks
the graph neural net this is individual
nodes here uh we see that
for majority of the nodes the graph
neural network is able to make
a correct prediction and it is very
certain about its prediction
and you know the class the prediction
the prediction performance is not
perfect
so there are a few mistakes but those
mistakes are also kind of borderline the
the network is
unsure about the classes of this uh of
these nodes
now if we apply uh uh
a direct adversarial attack um
then you can see how we can very easily
change um
the uh the the neural network to
basically always predict
to always make a mistake and be super
confident uh that it
in the end of wrong class so assign high
confidence in the
in the wrong class so this is a direct
attack
direct adversarial attack uh here is
what would happen
if the if it's still a direct attack but
it's a
random attack meaning we don't
adversarially strategically
change the the edges but we add edges
uh at uh random um and you see that
basically the neural network will get
confused
but not so badly right it uh still
majority it is making correct
predictions so definitely decreases
performance but not so drastically
if you look at indirect attacks where we
basically now manipulate
other nodes in the network and see if we
can change the label of the
of the target node here you see again
we are able to do this quite well
meaning for quite a few of the nodes we
are able to flip
uh their label so what this means is
adversarial direct attacks are very
strong and they can
they significantly worsen gnn
performance
random attack is much much weaker than
adversarial attack and somewhat
decreases
the performance while indirect attack is
uh less effective than direct but more
effective
uh than uh than direct random attack
so um what do we conclude from this is
that that
if the uh um adversary has access to the
full network has access to the to the
data and can manipulate it then it is
very easy
to change the predictions of these deep
learning
graph neural network models
so to summarize we studied the
adversarial robustness of graph
convolutional neural networks
applied to semi-supervised node
classification
we consider different attack strategies
different attack possibilities
uh in in in graphs we talked about
direct attacks as well as indirect
attacks uh we talked
we then mathematically formulated the
adversarial attack as an optimization
problem so this is the optimization
problem
that the adversary has to solve and we
looked at some examples to
empirically demonstrate that gcn's
prediction performance can be
significantly harmed
by adversarial attacks so what we
conclude is that
gcn is not robust against adversarial
attack
but it is somewhat robust to indirect
attacks
as well as to random noise and this
topic of robustness of these types of
methods is a topic of active research
and a very fruitful research area